cette fois pas de doute Peugeot a sorti
ses griffes compact rasés agressive la
205 GTI elle est moyen de ses ambitions
un lion sous le capot avec un 190 chrono
et le kilomètre départ arrêté en 31
secondes elle se présente comme la
rivale numéro 1 des golfes GTI bon
impression d'ensemble un poste de
pilotage sobre et bien fini la vitre
électrique petit volant lecteur de carte
individuelle et 5 vitesses pour
exploiter au mieux les 105 chevaux d'un
moteur de 1600 cm3 les accélérations
sont fabuleuses et la tenue de route
étonnante la 205 GTI est une traction
avant qui vire à plat les grandes
courbes les virages serrés peuvent se
négocier à vitesse élevée dans la plus
grande sécurité
là aussi c'est très bien on est très
bien tenu dans les
dans les sièges grâce à leur fabrication
ça ressemble un peu des sièges baquets
on est très bien tenu sur les côtés ce
qui est quand même agréable pour
négocier des virages de manière rapide
difficile de cacher son plaisir
de quoi la consommation raisonnable
Peugeot s'est voulu novateur séducteur
en s'investissant sur le meilleur
créneau du marché automobile en 1983 55
000 petites berlines à caractère
sportifs ont été vendus en France la
clientèle visée est large du retraitée
au coureur de rallye seul point commun
ils devront tous débourser 67000 francs
Peugeot engage un pari en 84 réussir la
greffe GTI
[Musique]